hola en este vídeo hablaremos de los
ciclos biogeoquímicos que hablan de vida
tierra y ciclos químicos entonces nos
hablan de como los químicos se mueven de
seres vivos a cosas que no están vivas y
de regreso y miren aquí arriba les he
puesto esta mnemotecnia para recordar
los átomos que necesita la vida para
sobrevivir
champs carbono hidrógeno oxígeno
nitrógeno fósforo y azufre pero antes de
hablar de los ciclos veamos por qué
necesitamos estos elementos pero traten
de ir adelante de mí es decir piensen en
por qué necesitamos todo esto empecemos
con el carbono porque necesitamos el
carbono
bueno recuerden que el carbono tiene 4
electrones de valencia es muy bueno para
formar enlaces y puede formar materiales
orgánicos complejos entonces si pensamos
en las proteínas o los lípidos o los
carbohidratos o en los ácidos nucleicos
como el adn todo esto se construye con
carbón y eso es porque el carbono es muy
bueno para formar algo consigo mismo ok
ahora veamos por qué es importante el
hidrógeno bueno el hidrógeno es
importante porque puede formar agua y el
agua es muy importante por muchas cosas
pero sobre todo porque con el agua la
vida puede existir por su capacidad como
solvente y por proveer un medio en el
cual la vida puede existir pero también
puede proporcionar energía por ejemplo
esta es una reacción de la fase luminosa
de la fotosíntesis y observen estos
protones que se mueven a través de la
atp sintasa generando energía en forma
de atp entonces el hidrógeno es
importante no solo por el agua sino
también por la transferencia de energía
y ahora veamos el oxígeno por qué es tan
importante bueno necesitamos el oxígeno
para formar el agua pero también es muy
importante en la respiración celular
porque miren al final el oxígeno recibe
los electrones y podemos generar una
gran cantidad de energía conforme esos
electrones se van con el oxígeno e
igualmente cuando se los quitamos en la
fotosíntesis se puede almacenar mucha
energía y bueno ahora tal vez estén
pensando y para qué necesitamos el
nitrógeno miren necesitamos el nitrógeno
por un par de cosas aquí tenemos un
aminoácido y recuerden que el adn
contiene la información para crear la
vida pero gracias a las proteínas somos
como somos entonces este es un
aminoácido y todos los aminoácidos
tienen un carbono en el centro unido a
un hidrógeno pero después tenemos un
grupo amino de un lado y un grupo car
box y lo del otro lado y después tenemos
un grupo r que es lo que le da la
diferencia a cada aminoácido pero miren
este nitrógeno es muy importante para
formar aminoácidos o proteínas por eso
necesitamos al nitrógeno para sobrevivir
y de este lado tenemos guanina y en
donde encontramos la guanina bueno si
hablamos del adn los que se encargan de
guardar la información son las bases
nitrogenadas la guanina es una pero
también tenemos a la citosina la timina
y a la adenina entonces en la guanina
aquí hay mucho nitrógeno así que
necesitamos nitrógeno de la atmósfera
para formar el material genético y ahora
veamos el fósforo para que necesitaremos
el fósforo bueno necesitamos fósforo
para varias cosas aquí tenemos un
fosfolípidos que forman las vi capas
lipídicas y aquí tenemos un grupo
fosfato y si analizamos el adn recuerden
que en el adn
tenemos azúcar fosfato azúcar fosfato
azúcar fosfato así que el fósforo es muy
importante en la formación de nuestro
material genético y algo que no puse
pero que también es importante es el atp
recuerden que el atp es trifosfato de
adenosina entonces con él
factor cuando unimos el tercer fosfato
podemos almacenar energía o podemos
liberar energía cuando lo dejamos ir y
finalmente veamos el más difícil azufre
para que necesitamos el azufre bueno
aquí he puesto dos aminoácidos cisteína
y metionina y ya aprendimos que un
aminoácido consiste en un grupo car box
y lo un grupo amino un carbono y un
hidrógeno pero podemos ver que en los
dos aminoácidos tenemos azufre y el
azufre es muy importante porque bueno
recuerden que las proteínas son las que
se encargan de hacernos como somos y
tienen una forma tridimensional muy
compleja entonces si tenemos un azufre y
un azufre con dos grupos cr se forma un
enlace como el que tenemos aquí a esto
se le conoce como puente de sulfuro o
enlace de sulfuro entonces el azufre es
importante porque le da la estructura a
las proteínas grandes por eso champs es
una buena forma de recordar
todos los elementos que necesitamos y ya
vimos que los necesitamos para
diferentes cosas por eso necesitamos
obtenerlos de nuestro medio ambiente y
miren si pensamos en cómo la energía
viaja desde el sol hasta la tierra
sabemos que viaja en forma de luz pero
una vez que llega a la tierra también se
convierte en calor entonces para que la
energía llegue a nuestro planeta se
mueve en una sola dirección y se
convierte en calor pero con los
nutrientes de nuestro planeta es
diferente porque los nutrientes se
reciclan por ejemplo la cantidad de agua
que tenemos en nuestro planeta es
estática la cantidad de carbono es
estática y son reciclados una y otra vez
en la biosfera en la tierra de hecho
trataron de hacer eso en el desierto de
arizona construyeron esto y lo llamaron
biosfera 2 trataron de mantener todos
los nutrientes que se necesitaban para
sobrevivir a dentro de esta biosfera que
permite la entrada de la luz pero
trataron de reciclar los nutrientes y
funcionó bien pero en realidad no
lograron un buen equilibrio así que de
vez en cuando tienen que abrirlo y bueno
recuerden que estamos hablando de los
ciclos biogeoquímicos como pasarán los
nutrientes de seres vivos a lo que no
está vivo bueno les mostraré cuatro
imágenes de cada ciclo el del agua
carbono nitrógeno y el del fósforo pero
me gustaría que piensen en dónde están
almacenados mayormente esos nutrientes
en nuestro planeta y cómo llegan a las
plantas a los animales y cómo regresan
al medio ambiente empecemos con un ciclo
que todos conocemos el ciclo del agua
ahora en donde se almacena la mayor
cantidad de agua en nuestro planeta
claro se encuentra en el océano
ese es nuestro depósito y como llega a
las plantas bueno por medio de la
evaporación condensación y precipitación
en algún momento llega a las plantas a
través de sus raíces que absorben el
agua así es como llega a las plantas y
cómo llega a los animales
bueno el agua llega a nosotros perdiendo
la o comiendo plantas que contienen agua
y como la perdemos es decir cómo regresa
a su origen bueno cómo saben las plantas
transpira pierden el agua a través de
sus hojas y nosotros la perdemos
mediante el sudor o al orinar así el
agua regresa al medio ambiente para que
se recicla de nuevo así que el agua que
guardamos en una botella en algún
momento se encontró en el océano en una
planta en un lago y así se va reciclando
una y otra vez ese es el ciclo del agua
ahora veamos el ciclo del carbono vamos
a ver la mayoría del carbono que existe
en nuestro planeta
almacena en la atmósfera pero como llega
a las plantas bueno llega a las plantas
por medio de la fotosíntesis porque
recuerden que las plantas absorben el
carbono mediante sus esto más y lo usan
para producir azúcares ok y cómo es que
se regresa al medio ambiente o cómo
llega a nosotros bueno nosotros comemos
plantas o animales que comen plantas y
así es como el carbono llega a nuestro
cuerpo pero como lo regresamos a la
atmósfera pues a través de la
respiración si respiramos regresamos el
carbono al medio ambiente al igual que
las plantas porque recuerden que también
respiran es sólo devuelve pero una cosa
que cambia la cantidad de carbono es por
la quema de combustibles fósiles eso
libera más carbono de lo que
naturalmente hay en la atmósfera pero
afortunadamente tenemos este maravilloso
reciclaje del carbón y para qué
necesitamos el carbón para construirnos
ok y ahora veamos el ciclo del nitrógeno
para que necesitamos el nitrógeno bueno
acuérdense para los aminoácidos y para
las bases nitrogenadas ahora en el ciclo
del nitrógeno de los dos lados
necesitamos bacterias entonces para que
el nitrógeno llegue a las plantas todo
empieza con el nitrógeno gaseoso de la
atmósfera recuerden que el 70% de lo que
respiramos es nitrógeno y para que
llegue a las plantas se necesitan
bacterias que lo que hacen es fijar el
nitrógeno así que antes de que la planta
pueda absorber el nitrógeno tiene que
ser fijado tiene que ser convertido a
nitrato y de eso se encargan las
bacterias incluso algunas plantas forman
una relación simbiótica con las
bacterias permitiéndoles que vivan en
sus raíces como en esta imagen pero una
vez que el nitrógeno se encuentra en las
plantas como pasa a los animales bueno
los animales
en plantas y nosotros comemos a los
animales que comen plantas pero en algún
momento tendremos que regresarlo a la
atmósfera y eso como ocurre bueno
nuevamente tenemos a las bacterias que a
través de la descomposición de la
materia las bacterias ayudan a devolver
el nitrógeno a la atmósfera entonces en
los dos lados del ciclo del nitrógeno se
necesitan bacterias para poder reciclar
al nitrógeno y finalmente veamos el
ciclo del fósforo en este caso el
fósforo no es almacenado en la atmósfera
como ocurre en el caso del nitrógeno y
el carbón o más bien el fósforo es
almacenado en las rocas y como llegará a
las plantas bueno cuando llueve el agua
desgasta la roca y la lleva hasta el
suelo en donde es asimilada es decir el
fósforo se absorbe a través de las
raíces de las plantas y así es como
pueden producir cosas como su material
genético o el atp
y como lo obtienen los animales bueno
cuando ellos se alimentan con las
plantas llevan el fósforo hacia ellos y
como lo regresarán al suelo bueno cuando
un ser vivo muere y se descompone
devuelve el fósforo y con el tiempo el
suelo se transforma y el fósforo regresa
a la roca así es como se recicla el
fósforo una y otra vez así que estos son
los ciclos biogeoquímicos con los que
podemos obtener los nutrientes los
tomamos del medio ambiente y también los
devolvemos espero que les sirva